ha teen annual project for awesome the
project for awesome is a teenager beans
beans is a bad perm that's that's not a
good idea
wait wait perk idea cosmic beans that is
a good idea but is not nice Oh what's
happening bro visual aids we've got dr.
but here you doing - geez like the
hosiery no but he's laughing but is the
top I think what is the thing that
happens about the life what is the thing
that happens above the legs sounds like
a ripoff of hope is the thing with
feathers but is definitely an atomic
liquid is let's really know John PIH is
all about social kind so so some
contacts it's very different scientific
context I love that and I love the way
that you're threatening the needle it's
beautiful I am at the 23rd Street
Chipotle and there's someone that I'd
like you to meet he's wearing armor he's
worn to the touch and he stands 9 maybe
10 feet
[Music]
look at what people can create something
different something grave can we just
please
you ever see this movie and thought I
wish it was more like a worm
I have not dropped out to save the rat
game yet for some to save the rap game
to save the rap game Hank green are a P
[Music]
so anyway I've got sharpie all over my
face are you saying we might currently
be with mrs. yes now I look like a
pixelated fool Bob by hey my goggles are
fogged my throat is in pain you want a
drink the milk no we've come this far
[Music]
don't anymore wake up thinking they're
going to learn about fly genitalia
because in a million
million three hundred and three thousand
three hundred and sixty dollars total
IndieGoGo that's wild what's man
what if 100 mile the last six I was my
happy dance award if it was all scream
most of the happy dance without
screaming scream
thank you again to everybody who made
this p4a happen and everybody who's been
with us for the last 48 hours leave
laughs next year god I'll see you on
Friday and everybody want the end